It is entirely possible that, for example, for this store and this load,
the store doesn't have the address at the time when the load
produces the address. And now, what do we do? The options for
this situation are. Make loads and stores execute in order.
So this load is not allowed to execute until all previous instructions have been
completed. That guarantees that at the time when we want to figure out what to
do with this load, we have all the store addresses and values so
we can have a situation just like this one here. But of course, the orders,
these instructions, so for example, loads cannot really proceed. So for
example, if this load has been a cache mission takes a long time,
all of these instructions will have to wait for that. The waiting can be
reduced by not waiting for all of these instructions to complete,
instead we just wait for all previous stored addresses to be known. Once we
now all the stored addresses, our load address can be compared with them and
then we know what to do. We either go to memory if nothing matches.
We get the value from the store if it is available or we wait for the store to
produce the value if the address matches but the store is not done yet
with its value. The third option is the most aggressive, and it is to just let
the load go anyway. So pretty much when we produce the address of the load,
we check the addresses of the previous stores. If one of them does match,
we wait for it, because clearly going to memory will be wrong. But if none of
them match, we ignore the fact that some of them might match once we resolve
their addresses. So in this situation, this load will end up going to memory.
Now two things can happen. One is, this store resolves to something like 74,
in which case we confirm that this was done, okay. Or
the store might actually get the address of 174 in which case this load
loaded the wrong value from memory. In that case we need to recover
this load loaded the wrong value and possibly supplied it to other instructions.
So in this case, the stores, when they produce the address will
check whether any of the loads that follow them match the address and were done.
And if so, then request a re-doing of the load and all of the subsequent
instructions to fix the problem of the load loading the wrong value.
Most modern processors today actually go with the go anyway option because it
produces the best performance. If we let the loads go without waiting for
store addresses, it turns out that most of the time we are right. So this
most of the time successfully loads the value earlier than if we waited. But
occasionally we have a cost of the recovery because we were wrong about this.
And then there are entire schemes that try to predict when is this going to
happen, let the loads go if it's unlikely and for loads that often conflict with
some store, wait for that store to produce the address before we proceed.